HONEST VOICE
Universal Pictures proudly presents the film
you realized had absolutely no dialogue whatsoever
- only after you bought your ticket.
HONEST VOICE (CONT'D)
Les Miserabablebles
Told in award-winning songs of beauty and
exuberance.
Except those sung by Russell Crowe.
RUSSELL CROWE
Unless you learned the meaning of the law.
I have made a false report. We may have met.
HONEST VOICE
Characters often singing about things that
could be very easily done by just talking
normally--
HELENA BONHAM CARTER
Go and draw some water from the well.
EPONINE
Hey there monsieur, what's new with you?
AMANDA SEYFRIED
Are you alright? Why did you go away?
HONEST VOICE
Seriously they sing everything, so to hit
that point even harder we thought we'd sing
the rest of the trailer.
SINGING VOICE
Meet the spirit of human redemption: Jean
Valjean. A paroled thief now on the run under
an assumed identity... for reasons never made
clear in the entire movie.
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
Who must face off against Inspector Javert...
An officer with such terrible priorities,
he'll put the entire city of Paris on lock
down to a stop a man who already served his
time.
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
Follow along in their epic game of cat and
mouse - that spans 20 years
Which is almost as long as the movie feels.
Meet Fantine... a random factory worker who
brings an incriminating letter to work for
no reason... and is fired--
Sinking into desperation so deep - she becomes
most pathetic woman in France - in just two
verses of song!
Watch her with no hair, watch her with no
teeth - yet she becomes the most desirable
prostitute in town - which she'll blame on
Hugh Jackman. Even though he had nothing to
do with it.
It's Anne Hathaway like you've never seen
her...
(Spoken)
Literally, she drops dead after only like
twenty minutes of screen time.
Leaving Valjean to now care for Cosette, her
precocious child who is scared of the dark--
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
But totally cool letting some stranger drag
her around the city.
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
Now, at the dawn of revolution... One young
man, will give up everything for a woman he's
met through a fence.
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
Prompting a heart-breaking romance we know
nothing about, because the entire subplot
is glossed over...
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
To make room for countless scenes of Borat!
Not since "The Dark Knight Rises" has a movie
been so manipulative with its use of time
jumps.
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
And not since Chicago, has a movie tried so
hard to convince you that movie musicals are
a good idea.
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
Featuring award-winning songs, but they all
sound the same, so without the track listing
you won't be able to tell one song from another.
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
Experience over 2 1/2 hours of CGI Crane Shots
and extreme close-ups.
SINGING VOICE (CONT'D)
And the death of Russell Crowe's acting ability.
HONEST VOICE
Starring...
HUGH JACKMAN
I have a very annoying vibrato.
ANNE HATHAWAY
I really, really, really wanted to win an
oscar!
RUSSELL CROWE
I should have never agreed to sing an entire
movie!
SACHA BARON COHEN
They really should have shown less of me and
more of Eponine!
HELENA BONHAM CARTER
Beetlejuice! Beetlejuice! Beetlejuice!
SINGING VOICE
If your girlfriend doesn't appreciate you
after sitting through this movie... Then you
should really rethink your relationship.
HONEST VOICE
Les Miserables.
HONEST VOICE (CONT'D)
Well that was fun! Now why not be a doll and
SUBSCRIBE! I'll get you my pretty. And your
little dog, too! NO SOUP FOR YOU! I can't
believe it's not butter. Ya'll gonna make
me loose my mind, up in here, up in here.
Go Ninja Go Ninja Go!